okay hi everyone uh it's my pleasure to
introduce Percy who's giving a guest
lecture for those of you who are in the
course uh just a reminder that the
poster session is on Wednesday next week
and your final project is due uh the
following
um or two weeks from from two days ago
or on Monday
um but uh really excited to introduce
Percy Percy is an associate professor
here at Stanford he's done some really
cool work in machine learning and
natural language processing uh both on
the theoretical side as well as the
empirical side and also has most
recently started the Stanford center for
research on Foundation models which has
also been kind of a really cool effort
going on is also pretty related to some
of the topics in the course as well so
yeah looking forward to this talk okay
all right thanks Chelsea for the
introduction and thanks everyone for
coming I think you guys have seen in
context learning a little bit I saw it
in one of the slides so hopefully we'll
do a little bit more of a deep dive here
um so the story starts in 2020 so a
bunch of people at open AI decided to
gather a ton of data Text data on the
internet
and construct a big Transformer and ask
the model to do one simple thing which
is predict the next word over and over
again over every single token on this
data set and they ran it on I think
something like 10 000 gpus for several
months and I think all of you know have
you know probably seen or played with
gpd3
but the the result I want to focus on is
this uh ability to do in context
learning so what is in context learning
just as a review it's idea that you can
prompt a language model with a string
which is concatenation of a bunch of
examples that's something that looks
like this with a new Test example and
ask the model to produce the answer
so if you think about this is sort of
crazy you know why would this you expect
that to work because language model
isn't supposed to generate language it's
not really supposed to solve any sort of
tasks let alone do some kind of meta
learning
and okay you might think well this is
because there's lots of examples that
look like this on the internet so I
should probably just copy something okay
so really tried hard to see if we could
break it so here's a task we prompt it
with input uh here's a date an output
you know we want to come up with
something that was definitely not on the
internet as of 2021 and
um it could reformat dates in this way
as well
okay so for those non-believers who
think like well okay gpd3 they train on
the internet they're just memorizing
well this is a clear demonstration
that's not just memorizing it's actually
learning some abstraction that's helping
it solve these tasks
okay
and and the scale matters here so this
is from the original gpt3 paper if you
were playing around with a small one
billion parameter models you could see
that nothing was really working at all
and it's only when you get up to 175
billion in that case
um you could get in context learning
so this is simply mind-blowing and ever
since I've been obsessed with the
problem of figuring out why it's uh this
works this is not the way machine
learning is supposed to work so uh
hopefully we can try to understand a
little bit of this in our talk here and
why in context learning is
matters and it's not just a random
curiosity
there's two reasons scientific and
practical the on a scientific front this
is an example example of emergent
phenomenon so gbd3 was not built to do
in context learning the developers did
not say oh we want in context learning
so therefore we're going to train it in
this way it just sort of emerged from uh
somehow from the data
second there's a sort of conventional
wisdom in machine learning that you
train and then you test and if you train
distribution is like your test
distribution then you win otherwise all
bets are off and this is going to be
farther from that setting where the
training distribution is predicting next
word and the test is this wide range of
Downstream tasks some of which have
never been seen at training time and yet
something is still working
and the the interesting thing about
emergence is that you know here we have
in context learning which is going to
occupy the whole of this talk but what
else is there people have looked at
other emerging Behavior like Chain of
Thought and so on and so there's a very
vast
um
uh set of capabilities that were barely
scratching the surface of
and then there's a practical concern or
um
aspect which is that in context learning
really presents a paradigm shift in the
way I think we build ml or AI systems so
now you can prototype new tasks in the
afternoon rather than you know setting
up some elaborate data collection
process so it kind of changes the way
that you even approach things and
you know I think it's also important to
realize that in the real world things
don't come pre-packaged with oh here's a
data set I can just download from
hugging face and just run it but if
you're actually trying to solve a real
problem there's usually a kind of a
vague idea of what you want to do maybe
some messy data and this idea of fast
and quick prototyping using these
language models I think allows you to
get a lot farther than if your first
step was to collect a bunch of data and
label it
okay so diving a little bit into details
um so there's a contrast here two types
of learning the first is what I call
Standard learning it's gradient base
which is what everyone's familiar with
that you take gradients in context
learning the key operation is not
gradient descent but conditioning
so in the language model remember it's a
distribution over a sequence of tokens
so what you're really doing is
conditioning on a sequence of tokens and
then asking them all to predict the next
thing
okay so we'll come back to the issue of
conditioning in the second part of the
talk
and since this is a meta learning class
I thought I'd try to clarify the
relationship between meta learning and
context learning which often it gets
blurred so there's a form of meta
learning which you guys talked about
which is Black Box meta learning and I
think of metal learning is talking about
the framework of
um you have training data that has maybe
a collection of tasks and you want to do
some sort of training procedure so that
the model in this case a black box model
can do learning on new tasks so I think
about this is the connection between you
know the training and inference time
and into context learning really refers
to the ability that a model has
and you know independent of where it
came from
so we can talk about the in-context
learning ability of a transformer that
was I don't know hand coded or learned
from
supervised examples or from language
modeling objectives
okay
feel free to interrupt if you have any
questions
okay so in order to understanding
context learning I want to break things
down into two pieces one is just the
question of how a fixed model
you know never mind where it came from
how can a fixed model even perform in
context learning because this is just a
giant Transformer it's getting fed in a
bunch of uh you know sequence of
examples and it has to do something some
you know association between the accents
of
um y's
um to be able to predict so how is that
possible and the second question is how
do you get one of these models from
training let's say on next word
prediction
so I'm not going to answer these two
questions fully but we're going to try
to make some progress
and how can we make some progress well
there's there's many things going on
with gpd3 so let me try to break it down
so there's a question of data you know
the gbt3 was trained on the large web
crawl
you know what is necessary there can we
demonstrate in a constant learning with
synthetic data there's a question of
model architecture so we've seen in Cox
learning working for Transformers what
about rnns or mixer of experts and then
there's a training objective
does it have to be unaggressive can it
be sort of like a contrastive or mass
language model objective
and then there there's a question of you
know how do you study in each of these
components
um you can understand things
theoretically where we develop a toy
model and then you can you know prove
analytically why in context Learning
Works
um or you can run synthetic experiments
where you develop a simple model and you
can run things so you can get you know
clean conclusions
and then there's real world experiments
where you're running things on real
language and so
um and there's trade-offs right
ultimately we want to be in the real
world but this is really messy and it's
also very expensive because remember in
context Colonial in shops up at scale so
you can't really hope to do that many
real world experiments so what we're
going to focus on is the bolted pieces
here we're going to look at synthetic
experiments and do a little bit of
theory to understanding context learning
both the Arctic texture and the data
so we're going to talk about two works
the first is uh trying to get at the
architecture question and the second is
trying to get at the data question
okay so the first paper is with uh
Shivam Dimitris and Greg Valiant
appearing at nerups
um
okay so in context learning is
um you can solve all these different
tasks but
you know there's a nagging question that
I think I alluded to earlier which are
these models actually doing any learning
at all or is it just pattern matching
you know you should be really suspicious
of these language models
um
so what we want to do is formalize the
problem a bit right because I think in
Catholic learning like what's the
definition so here is a definition which
captures I think an
um you know at least one aspect of it
so you can think about in context
learning of a function class so this is
hailing back to kind of what people do
in statistical learning theory where
what does it mean to learn
it's you define a function class and you
create examples from that class and then
you see if your learning algorithm can
figure out which function it is okay so
we're going to play the same game here
so for example linear functions the set
of all linear functions and let's say 20
Dimensions you sample a function
and then you're going to sample random
inputs so these are going to be vectors
that are D dimensional
and or I'm going to say okay here's X1
I'm going to apply the function to X1
here's X2 apply the function of X2 and
these are going to be inputs into a
model and I want the model to be able to
Output the corresponding function value
of the last input here
okay
and the model architecture we're going
to look at for this talk this first part
of the talk is a Transformer
it's worth noting that the x is a real
value so this is not going to be a
language Transformer here x is just
going to be I mean it's it's basically
the word embedding treat it as a word
Bend bedding layer for the the
Transformer
and instead of outputting you know a
soft Max over tokens we're going to have
this Transformer just directly have
attach a linear layer and actually ask
it to do regression using the squared
loss
okay so slightly deviation from actually
a pure language model so this is why
we're just talking about Transformers as
opposed to language models there's no
language or text here at all
okay so then what are we going to do
we're going to build this Transformer by
sampling functions over and over again
and for each function we're going to
sample data for that function and then
ask the Transformer to reconstruct the
labels in the data
okay this is going to be doing from
scratch just to make a very clear what's
what's going on rather than uh
pre-training and fine-tuning
okay so what can uh this train
transformer do
so let's start with linear functions in
20 Dimension this plot shows as you
increase the number of in-context
examples
um you know what is the error rate on
the kind of the fresh straw and here
we're looking at
um least squares
and this is what you would expect
there's no noise in the problem so the
dimensionality is 20 which means that if
you get 20 points then you basically
know the function and least squares is
optimal you can't do better than that
and here the Transformer is actually
able to match the implementation of
these squares and just to check we do
some naive things like averaging and
nearest neighbors and they just don't
work right so the Transformer seems to
be mimicking the behavior of the optimal
algorithm here of these squares
so okay so this was pretty cool
but you might still be suspicious okay
well maybe you just saw enough examples
and it just kind of memorized all the
possible linear functions if you do the
math there are a lot of linear functions
even if they're Epsilon close like it's
you know cursive dimensionality you know
exponential 120 is pretty big so it's
definitely not seen all the um you know
linear functions
um but you know you should still be
suspicious and so let's probe it a
little bit okay so how yeah measure if
it's doing these spurs are you like
measuring if it's outputting the pseudo
inverse or something like that so the
question is how do you know if it's
doing least squares so we're only
looking at the prediction error
so it's most certainly not implementing
the least squares algorithm and I'll
show you uh you know
for a fact but it's at least on this
distribution it's uh behaving like if
you had run many squares
Yeah question America
order the input examples matter in this
case or if you like reordered the inputs
like the X1 X2 X game we're showing
they're probably in some particular
order or could you shuffle them and kind
of get the same results yeah so the
question is does the order of the
examples matter in this case it doesn't
really matter because each of these X's
are actually generally drawn ID
so there's no information in the
ordering
okay so let's try to probe it and the
way to really check whether a
you know this model is able to in
context learning is let's try to give it
inputs that it hasn't seen at training
time not not just hasn't seen but it's a
different distribution and the
distributions here are a little bit
complicated so let me try to talk
through it so there's the distribution
over X's at
um test time so when I say test and
train I really mean meta test and meta
train
um just and when I say query that's like
the the I guess maybe where you would
call the test Point
um
so uh there's a distribution of x's
there's a distribution over the Y's
given by the function and then there's
this query point
okay so I'm going to change these and
and for there's basically these
distributions for meta test and then
there's also these distributions for
metatrain so there's really like six
different different distributions that
we can vary
um
so here's one starting point so remember
at training time meta training time we
draw a
examples just from a standard gaussian
and at test time what we're going to do
is we're going to give these X's which
are the in context examples they're
going to come from a different quadrant
or orthand than the query
okay so let's see what happens in this
case it degrades a little bit but it's
basically matching the behavior of least
squares maybe this transition isn't as
sharp it needs a few more examples to
figure out what's going on but not too
bad
what happens if we remember in training
time we had identity covariance in a
test time all the x's and the q's are
going to be drawn from a different
covariance distribution where the
covariance is skewed
and here you definitely get some
degradation so it doesn't hit zero as it
should least squares would hit zero
because well there's no training uh in
in these squares or no meta training in
these courses a fixed algorithm
and so it but it's not bad okay so this
is why it's not exactly these squares
but it's a sort of approximately of
these squares
so here's something really interesting
so what happens if you add label noise
at uh inference time so in training
there's no noise so we're using the same
Transformer here and at test time you do
add some label noise
so here least squares is actually
going to not work because if you're at
least squares actually blows up here and
this is a phenomenon called double
descent which has been you know pretty
well studied and learning theory
and the Transformer interestingly has a
similar Spike
okay so this is sort of interesting I
mean this is I guess I don't know if
this is good or bad but at least
qualitatively it has some similarities
to least squares at least as measured by
this kind of reaction against noise
um even though it's not exactly these
squares
okay so the conclusion there is that
yeah
yeah sort of works um like these squares
so what about going Beyond linear
function classes
so let's look at sparse functions so in
the sparse function the F's have zeros
in a lot of places on the wave Vector
except for maybe three entries
so here the optimal thing is not least
squares least squares is going to take
20 examples to figure out what the
solution is it's the lasso algorithm
which does L1 regularization and here we
show that the Transformer actually
learns to behave like the lasso so this
is pretty cool because now the
Transformer is able to learn
kind of non-trivial I mean the lasso is
not a trivial algorithm and exploding
sparsity is not trivial so it's able to
do that which is pretty cool note that
we did have to train the Transformer to
do this so it's not it's not magic
um
otherwise it wouldn't know about
sparsity at all what about a two-layer
value Networks so here the Baseline that
we looked at is gradient descent and it
basically matches graded Ascent so
that's that's nice
um
the original um Transformer that you
trained on non-sparce things and see if
it matches these squares so the question
is if I took the original Transformer
and applied it to the sparse question so
this should match the least squares
um objective
um because you know this this is
sparkling effect is just a special case
of linear functions and we already know
that
um the previous Transformer acted like
least square is on a fairly wide range
of distributions
yeah so the label noise is just adding
calcium noise
so the question is how well to work if
you gave it uh one Y which is way out
there
um that would probably break Lee squares
uh because at least unless you're right
so least squares has no regularization
right it's not rich regression so it's
going to just be thrown off by that
label and the Transformer we didn't do
that exact experiment but I imagine that
it would be also uh you know distracted
yeah Chelsea
um given that like these squares is kind
of the optimal solution when you don't
have noise
are
prizing like I guess I would
I think yeah I guess do you think it's
surprising or like or did any of these
results kind of differ from what you
were expecting
so the question is basically is this
results surprising
um it was not obvious to me that this
Transformer would have this type of
behavior
um and in fact I'm not going to talk
about this but we also ran experiments
with lstms and lcms look like
Transformers on the indistribution but
on this case lstms did not have the
double descent so it's pretty
non-obvious I think that you know the
arc there's some dependence on the
architecture depending on like different
architecture have a different inductive
bias which will lead to different
quote-unquote algorithms that it's
learning is that just because the
Transformer is fitting the data better
like is it better Universal function
approximator basically
is so the question is is that because a
Transformers just
um
that fitting the train either I don't
think so I think it is inductive
advisory because we did I mean
there's still more work to be done but I
we try to make the LCM large so it
wasn't like a capacity issue it could be
a training llcm is a hard you know to
train so not not quite sure
the intuition behind why double descent
happens this is maybe a longer question
so maybe we should take that offline but
basically I guess one
um quick a quick answer is that in the
over parameter regime so statistically
what you would expect is like okay you
fit and then you start overfitting when
there's noise if there's no noise then
there's there's no overfitting because
you just nail it and what people have
observed is that over parameterization
uh you know when the number of
Dimensions is larger than the number of
examples you could kind of get this sort
of optimal error but you know happy to
chat more later we should uh let me go
on so we have a lot to cover but good
questions
um okay so finally we look at decision
trees so for decision trees we looked at
the greedy algorithm XG boost which is
the state of our decision Tree Learning
algorithm and here the Transformer
actually outperforms
um the the actually at least on this
sort of synthetic data distribution so
this is not claiming that you should
ditch xgbooths and use this Transformer
but this is sort of curious I think that
the Transformer is able to learn some
sort of algorithm at least on this
distribution it's outperforming sort of
hand-coded algorithms so to speak
um model size
clearly matters but what's interesting
is that model size is especially
important when you look at kind of
robustness and extrapolation to out of
distribution
um you know for standard it seems like
okay there's a steady Improvement as you
increase the model size but it sort of
really matters if you're extrapolating
um okay so let me summarize
so one conceptual important thing to
take away is that we're defining in
context learning of a function class so
this is sort of a maybe a important
concept not to think about in context
learning as like some fuzzy thing but
we're talking about rigorously in
context learning of a function class and
this is a property of a model
um but in order to sort of prove the
existence of these models we can train
our Transformers to do in context
learning on these linear functions we
saw we could do sparse linear functions
neural networks decision trees we also
evaluate the robustness of the
Distributing prompts which I think is
really crucial if you want to understand
because many of the differences between
model size and lstms versus Transformers
you don't really see unless you go out
of distribution because that's where the
inductor biases really kick in and I
think it's sort of interesting to think
about what algorithms these Transformers
are representing
um there's still a lot of open questions
here
um
this model when you condition on these
in context examples
is a function
it's not a linear function certainly
but it is a function that sort of local
in I think within a ball behaves sort of
linearly and it'll be interesting to
understand what function that actually
is
I alluded to rnns and lstms
um how much of this is specific to
Transformers as opposed to other
architectures
um how can we look underneath the hood
to see what Transformers are actually
doing mechanism mechanalistically
there's this follow-up paper I think
which is really interesting where they
actually are able to construct a
Transformer by setting its weights
somehow and show that that can do linear
regression
they also do some more like probing
experiments to look inside the
Transformer whereas we are only looking
at behaviors
um what question is you know can we get
algorithmic insights this is something
I'm kind of excited about because
um you know this will maybe teach us
something about algorithm you know
design and the idea that the decision
trees case the Transformer was actually
able to do so much better suggests maybe
there are other sort of algorithms or
principles here that we can pull out
um and finally this is all on synthetic
tasks it'd be great to tie this back
into real tasks with knowledge and the
exclusion of knowledge here is
deliberate here because we wanted to
understand in context learning the
really the learning part and this is
sort of you can think about this as a
pure learning like all we know is is a
learning function there's no knowledge
it's just like figure out what the
linear function is this is just learning
a lot of the in context examples that
you see
in literature bring in prior knowledge
um about
um you know translation there's no way
obviously you can learn how to translate
sentences from five examples it has to
be knowledge and how does that work in
conjunction with this learning ability
that's I think a really interesting
question
um question back there
have a quick one here uh it seems like
there is some threshold right based on
model size of the number of writers
which is why I do context learning
happens
this will work did you do the analysis
on that like for instance get
s guitar the number of parameters you
got your model would it not learn to do
this lasso type regression
um you know is there a way to estimate
how many parameters you need for for
your model given to some level of task
difficulty yeah that's a great question
so the question is uh you know basically
how big of a model do you need for
certain types of behaviors
um
we have this experiment which is show
that I mean size definitely does matter
I think it'll be really interesting to
do a more careful scaling loss type of
analysis where you train a sequence of
models from small to large and maybe you
um increase the depth or the number of
tension heads and look at these sort of
dimensions of scaling and then track the
different types of behaviors like did I
learned in the lasso did it
um you know match uh does it have double
descent and so on
um yeah that would be
interesting follow-up work
so like wondering does this show
ing in context learning from
Transformers to throughout new networks
so the question is Transformers can be
seen as a special case of graph neural
networks are there any works at
exploring context learning with graph
neural networks
um
I think that
I mean there's independently I think
interest in thinking about how you do in
context learning with graph structured
data
um which uh you know is I think
interesting to explore I think here
um
you know I guess
there's
you know the graphs I guess with the
best sense what you're trying to get out
of the graph neural network here there's
you know you have a sequence of X Y
Pairs and there is in some sense a
symmetry they're sort of all k
Square different kind of connections
that make sense so I don't know if there
would be a natural graph structure I
guess that the asymmetry between the X
and the Y tokens maybe matter so you
could try to sparsify the graph or play
with attention heads
um you know somehow I mean a broader
question is you know the Transformer has
you know we have positional embeddings
here which seems rather unnatural from
the point of view of it's not order
invariant and someone asked about the
the dependence on ordering of examples
maybe you can build that in variants um
directly into the model
any other questions
um so the question is do you did we do
an experience without the positions
um it wouldn't work because then you
don't know which y goes with which X
because if it's just a bag of X Y pairs
you don't
yeah they're separate tokens
yeah yeah
okay
so to the outline so we talked about uh
what Transformers can learn in context
looking at
um I think about it really is an
architectural question can the
Transformer do certain things and doing
a bunch of synthetic experiments on
well-defined function classes to explore
the limits of Transformers
now let's try to understand uh the role
of data although the way we'll kind of
get at the data Maybe is not what you
think it would be
um so this is a I clear paper with
Michael Shia Aditi raganathan and Tanya
and remember there's two types of
learning standard learning you think
about gradients
and in context learning is this maybe
weird thing where you condition to do
learning
but maybe it's not actually that weird
if you think about it with your with a
Bayesian through a Bayesian lens
and if you think about Bayesian
inference
um
which might be you know a different
Paradigm for you know the that I guess
the you know the norm
um in ml these days
um so let's walk through what Bayesian
inference is so
imagine you have a latent a random
variable Theta which is a corresponds to
a task you can think about it as a
function a linear function if you want
which is unknown that's why it's not
shaded and you think about the the
building a generative model over what um
okay that's General model is overloaded
these days let's build a probabilistic
and framework for thinking about how a
Theta is related to variables so here's
a simple example let's suppose that we
have X1 and y1 so
um suppose you know you can generate X1
or you can just condition on it it
doesn't matter but the point is that Y
is uh
generate a given X and Theta and
independently for each of the K examples
we have y
um given X and Theta
and then you have a query point which is
just another ID example and it's you ask
what is the probability of Y query given
x square root of theta
and now now of course you don't know
what Theta is
so being a good Vision you would just
try to marginalize it out and that's
what this equation does so this is a
very classic kind of Bayesian
analysis where you have this posterior
distribution where you condition on
everything that you observe which is
this and then you look at the posterior
distribution over Theta so you're trying
to guess what Theta is and then you
basically kind of wait
um your prediction so this is the
prediction if you have Theta how would I
predict on y query given X query
and you're basically averaging over
possible values of theta which where the
averaging is given by the posterior
so this object in in Bayesian analysis
is called the posterior predictive
distribution it doesn't have a Theta in
it because it's a bit marginalized out
so it just looks like X1 y1 all the way
to x k y k x query and probably the
distribution of Y query right and this
is exactly the same form that we've been
playing around with when we talk about
doing in context learning
okay
so from through this lens what we can
think about
in context learning or these
Transformers doing is that they're
trying to fit this posterior predictive
distribution directly
okay but there could be this underlying
structure here that is latent
but the Transformer you know doesn't
care it's just going to fit this
distribution and maybe it has
some notion of implicitly Theta maybe it
doesn't who knows
so what will be
useful to think about is this posterior
predictive distribution and we're going
to start a kind of abstracting away from
the architecture and we're just going to
talk about the distribution okay so
remember our questions
you know how can a fixed model a
Transformer perform in context learning
and the first part of talk shows some
empirical evidence that the Transformer
can do in context learning in a fairly
wide number of non-trivial settings
um
and if you are shown examples
of the task essentially now there's some
extrapolation to allow the domain but
largely you're showing the Transformer
here's how what linear regression looks
like
and so you can think about through this
lenses well I just um this is the model
I mean accurate depiction of um
the linear regression setup if for
appropriate choices of distributions and
so you can think about it what we're
doing is we're just fitting this
distribution and if you believe that a
Transformer is some Universal function
approximator if you give enough data it
should just work right I think still
it's not trivial
um
that I can do it in a reasonable amount
of time because you know the Universe I
mean you can invoke Universal function
approximator to you know this is a
pretty could be a pretty complex
function so that the Transformer can
learn it and you can actually run sdg to
do it it's not obvious that's what the
first part of the talk show that it's
you know it sort of works
um but now we're going to move on to the
second question is how does this model
rise from training
and and the key thing is that you know
remember in gpd3 is just between our
next word prediction
so it's a very it's not explicitly
training for these tasks which is the
whole point of emerging behavior and
this is really the I think the harder
question or conceptually harder question
to ask
okay so the main challenge here is this
distribution shift right we're training
on basically internet crawl and we're
prompting it with examples that don't
show up at training or even out of
distribution so the pre-training
distribution is not the same as the
prompting distribution and can be
actually pretty wildly different
so in what settings can this actually
work
so
we're going to try to make some progress
by defining a simple model where the
pre-training distribution and prompting
distribution differ in a well-controlled
way and then we're going to see if we
can make some progress okay
so
we're going to consider pre-training
distribution as a mixture of hmms and
the idea is that you have this this
concept Theta that encodes for example
the topic like oh this is a Wikipedia
biography let's say and then given that
which encodes let's say the transitions
of hmm then we're going to generate text
from that hmm
okay so to generate a document you first
sample transitions from this hmm and
then you're going to sample the hidden
States from hmm and then do the sample
of the emissions given the the trans the
hidden States okay and then you get your
text and you remember your hide Theta
because you don't see it
but that's to the data generating
process for the pre-training data
okay
so now let's think about what language
modeling would try to do if it's asked
to just predict this text
I would argue that it's implicitly has
to infer the target concept somehow
um I know this is a little bit hand wavy
but you know bear with me so if you have
this article about Albert Einstein it it
kind of needs to figure out okay well
this is probably like a Wikipedia
biography and invoke you know I'm going
to generate things that look like
Wikipedia biographies
so the LM will probably try to
implicitly infer Theta approximately
somehow and then try to sample from the
hmm
so of course the Transformer is not
literally doing this but this is just a
kind of a cartoon of what it might be
thinking
okay so now what about the prompting
distribution we're going to find the
prompting distribution as we're going to
choose
a Target concept Theta star so we're
going to fix it and then we're going to
generate from the hmm But we're going to
break it up into independent pieces
and here we can have Albert Einstein
with German delimiter uh Gandhi was an
Indian delimiter and and so on
right so this part is generated from the
hmm and then once you hit a delimiter
you reset and go back to sort of initial
State and you generate from hmm again
and you reset and you generate
information member again
okay so this distribution is different
from the the training distribution
because it has basically these restarts
as opposed to one long continuous hmm
and this corresponds to the fact that in
general in documents you have topic
coherence you know Albert Einstein you
if you have a Wikipedia page of Albert
Einstein and then in these in context
examples you're sort of quickly changing
the the topic but you're sort of it's
still the hmm but you're kind of
resetting the topic
um in this in a sense
Okay so
so now the question is
okay if what will the language model do
on these this prompting distribution
and
what you would like what you hope is
that the language model could still
infer this target concept
and then it can generate from this hmm
and then if it could if it knows data
star then you would be done and you
would just uh
um because this is Mariah Carey was
polished it's just Journey from hmm
but the difficulty is
the distribution mismatch you're now
going to condition this language model
on samples
from The Prompt distribution
and remember the prompting distribution
is different from the training
distribution
okay
so that's the kind of the technical
hurdle here otherwise it's sort of just
standard
um
it should be clear that it works from
standard Vision Theory yeah
[Music]
is there also like in
fact
I keep reading words and like this
yes so the question is like what are the
hidden states in the hmm I haven't shown
them here
um but you can think about
um let's see what's the best
um Theta is defining the transition
probabilities of hmm and then the way
you sample this text is you have a
hidden State and you transition
according to the probability specified
by Theta and then you emit given those
hindenses so I haven't shown them
because they're sort of
um I don't know might not be
interpretable
you can think about this basically let's
say one through
you know 50 hidden States or something
okay so the key challenge here is that
the prompt distribution is different
from the pre-training distribution and
and what's and here's a visualization so
in the in context learning examples you
have transitions that according to hmm
and then which are in distribution so
that's great
um and then you have these low
probability transitions where you're
like here's the limiter and then I'm
going to start going from Einstein to
Gandhi all of a sudden
so those are low probability under the
language model because uh you you just
don't see this kind of
um you know text too often at training
time
so then the the okay so then what can
you do so here's maybe the most
technical slide this is just still a
sketch so we proved the result which is
makes assumption and the assumption
intuitively is the signal that you get
about Theta so the difference between
the true concept and any other concept
um
was measured by kind of the observation
distribution has to be larger than this
error that you get from these low
probability transitions
so these two transitions are the source
of distribution shift and if you
compound the distribution shift in terms
of some separation then we show that um
as in context Learning Works in the
sense that as a number of uh examples K
goes to Infinity
then
in context like this this language model
will ultimately predict the right thing
okay so it's an asymptotic result but
this is sort of the type so so know that
notice that if you didn't have the
distribution mismatch this would just
follow through kind of standard Bayesian
asymptotics and that would be fine so
the key thing is that now you have this
error that you have to account for and
under some conditions this is still
still works
okay so maybe some practical takeaways
um you know from the theory are
um and you know you don't need the
theory to make these practical takeaways
but it's maybe good to understand the
takeaways and the concept of the theory
is that making the prompting
distribution as close to the training
distribution
um helps and you see the large
literature on prompting basically tries
to finagle things so that's the case for
example if you prompt if you want to
know capitals then you try to say Berlin
is the capital of Germany and and so on
using natural language so it looks more
in distribution so this is a kind of a
prompting trick
so you generally want to use the
limiters that are like new lines or
pounds that don't increase the
probability of inferring the wrong
concept so through this kind of latent
concept view what you're basically doing
is that every time you you think about
infirming hmm every time you're
transitioning this is sort of confusing
the model and if you have
instead of a new line you say something
like birth date that's going to really
confuse the model so don't do that using
something neutral is uh is helpful
okay so then I'm going to switch into
some empirical
studies here
I mean the first is we built this data
set
um generating context learning data set
and the goal is to have something small
so we can run experiments and study
things without training waiting weeks to
train large models and so there's a
pre-training distribution of a thousand
documents each document is just one long
sequence a sampled from hmm and um it
basically looks like this so it's sort
of gibberish just
and the prompting distribution is uh
concatenated independent examples so
it's basically the same distribution of
gibberish with punctuated by these
dileminers
okay so we trained Transformers and
lstms on the pre-training distribution
which is just these documents and then
condition on this prompting distribution
and see if it could predict the right
answer and as the number of in context
examples increases we see that the
Transformer
um
uh improves so K here is the length of
an example so here the K is 3 for
example
and
and we see that as a length of example
increases then things get better this
should be you know natural because the
more lengthier the in context examples
here are than the more indistribution
the the the
um this prompting distribution looks
and here lcms are actually doing a
little bit then Transformers which might
be also natural because this data set is
basically like a hmm I mean it's a
mixture of hmm so it's not exactly an
hmm but it has this sort of temporal
sequence and maybe that matches the
inductive bias of lstms better than
Transformers which have to work harder
um effective modeling uh scale so you
know I think the scale is obviously a
top of mind question Yeah question
so the question is as K increases it
seems like this is catching up with k
equals 10.
um
I think it's just a diminishing gains
that you get because 8 and 10 aren't
that different but if going from three
to five is almost you know like doubling
the size
um and if k equals one then you really
don't have much information
um
yeah there's some noise here so
yeah
okay so what happens when you increase
the model scale
so
you know things the common refrain is
that when models get better things get
better but one thing that's interesting
is that
the in context accuracy will get better
as you improve them increase the model
size let's say from 12 to 16 but
um the validation loss or the the
pre-training loss is
the same
so this is sort of interesting because
it's it's not you're not fitting the
data you know better
by using a larger model
we don't know if we can understand why
this is the case but maybe just a
hypothetic hypothesizing maybe there's
inductive bias for in context learning
that improves it with model size yeah
not really sure
um then we look at some
we're trying to sort of see whether this
data set kind of captures a lot of the
phenomena that you see in the literature
so there's this peculiar thing of the
gpd3 paper that zero shot is sometimes
better than one shot for some you know
data sets and you see the same thing
kind of happened in you know uh as well
um which is sort of interesting
um
there's a paper
that did a really interesting experiment
um so this is for the Skeptics of in
context learning like okay are you
actually doing in concert learning or
not
um yeah question what is the reason why
um
yeah so the question is is zero shot
better than one shot just simply because
the model is copying
um the last answer and that's generally
I think the what happens because you
have only one example then sort of the
model can't really tell the difference
between okay the constant function what
I always want to Output this answer
versus actually doing some in context
learning
yeah
um so
so this is an interesting experiment so
they took the sentiment
you know data set
and what they did was just randomize the
labels so I'm just going to randomly
replace positive neutral negative with
some other labels
and then you see if in context learning
still works
so if you were doing normal learning
this would be crazy right you would just
completely to get destroyed because
there's no signal
uh but what they found across a bunch of
different models and you know tasks and
data sets is that
um the amount of drop that you get from
gold labels versus random labels is
actually not that much and sometimes I
don't know why this increases but gpa3
it dips very little compared to not
having demonstrations at all
so this is sort of interesting so
clearly you know in context learning
sort of different from normal supervised
learning
um one way you can kind of see this
through the the Bayesian lens is that
um is that the in context inputs
help us nail down what the target
concept is despite the noisy labels so
you're still conditioning on X so that's
giving you valid information about Theta
and the only problem is that these y's
are now just junk
but you know this is where it's a little
bit speculative maybe because there's
noise there's no information in them so
so certainly if you were missing the Y's
then that's strictly better because
you're able to infer the task better and
then you can predict and if they're
random maybe that's sort of like a
marginalized out I mean not
mathematically but
um that's sort of intuition that your
conditioning on x's and sort of the the
Y's are just random so they're kind of
ignored
um so this is maybe one example where
the Bayesian inference perspective gives
you a little bit of
insight into this empirical phenomena
here's another example that we don't
explain so this is very similar so here
let's suppose in context examples are
the task is to predict whether
something's a sport
animal or plant or vegetable
um and the labels have shoved and
shuffled so they're not random but
they're sort of deterministically
shuffled
and in this case
um you know gbd3 is actually able to
um respect that shuffling
so this is something that's not captured
by our framework because this is sort of
a more of an abstract kind of reasoning
capability
that gpg3 has where it's able to
associate
sort of basically do variable binding
it's like basically sport is just a
variable that has a particular meaning
in this context and I'm going to use it
consistently to mean that thing which is
sort of really cool if you think about
it despite the strong prior that sport
is is Sport now in this context it's I
guess vegetable
so
Mysteries
okay let me try to summarize this
section
so I want to argue that Bayesian
inference is a useful way to think about
in context learning because really
Bayesian inference is all about
conditioning and in context learning all
you're doing is conditioning on your
income tax samples
and
Invasion inference the key object is of
a serial predictive distribution which
is exactly the thing that uh you know
you're trying to approximate when you're
training a model to do in context
learning
the main challenge is to analyze
the case where the pre-training and the
prompting distribution are just you know
different we showed some kind of mild
theoretical progress why if you bound
the errors of the transitions then of
the low probability transitions then you
can prove something you know reasonable
one important note is that all these
results here in the second part of the
talk are independent of the architecture
and I I think this is interesting
because now understanding in context
learning is through this lens is all
about understanding the differences
between
you know the pre-training distribution
and the prompting distribution
which you have analytical so there's no
like sample complexity it's just like
these two distributions and what happens
if you condition on a draw from an OED
distribution and ask the model to
predict on your kind of ID distribution
and this might be useful for
understanding the role of data because
if you think about the role of data you
want to solve these tasks you have the
web corpora
maybe there's a way to use this
framework to understand you know data
distributions and their relationships
and we also have this small synthetic
data set which is based on a mixture of
xmms which hopefully can allow you to
run experiments really quickly and
assess and answer some questions
Okay so
to wrap it up we looked at three or two
different
projects one is to understand the
um whether Transformers can do in
context learning of a function class and
the second thinking about uh in context
learning as Vision inference
um
so final slide here
so influences learning is I think one of
these great Mysteries I think that we
have in modern Ai and it's it's sort of
becoming a foundation for many AI
applications so people are using them to
just build new application in increasing
applications that didn't exist before
because you can kind of spin them up so
quickly
and I think understanding is certainly
lacking and I think it's it's sort of
key to make both making scientific
progress but also engineering better
systems because these in context
learning systems are not reliable
right we don't understand how they work
and sometimes they work sometimes they
don't
and this talk takes a particular
view that you know synthetic setups can
help us more rigorously explore so I
think it's also valuable to run real
experiments on real data and you know
we're doing a bunch of that but you know
there's only so much kind of handle you
can get on what's going on and I think
we've gotten a few insights into the
role of model architectures and the role
of Data Solutions by focusing on this
much more controlled setting
and now the big open question is you
know what if this can you kind of link
up with the real world settings
um which bring in knowledge and prior
knowledge and there's clearly a bunch of
things phenomena that are not captured
here
and there's more Beyond in context
learning so there's another emerging
phenomena such as Chain of Thought
ability to do arithmetic
a lot of other things that are hidden
inside these large language models which
you know are waiting to be kind of
discovered so it's like really kind of
exciting because it's doing like
scientific discovery rather than purely
engineering
and maybe one final thought is that you
know we're kind of scrapping the idea of
a of a task which has been so Central to
machine learning because what these
language models
allow you to do is sort of Define not
just Define tasks on the fly but sort of
fluidly go between tasks like when you
have you know instructions which we
haven't really analyzed or you know
talked about paired with you know maybe
a few examples that feels like
that's maybe one task but then
the idea that it's just a language model
there's no it doesn't have a notion of a
task specifically which means that maybe
having a task-based framing could be too
limited to understand kind of truly
what's what's happening in the language
model
so end there and happy to take questions
thank you
um
so the question is can you use knowledge
distillation to move things more into
the fine-tuning regime
uh so maybe
well one one answer is that
I think there's a great deal of interest
in taking language models and doing
additional fine-tuning to improve their
in context learning behaviors so this is
typically what happens when people do
what is called instruction tuning where
you have you know exam things that look
like more like tasks
and this definitely helps
and it helps
quite a bit more than just scaling up of
course you scale up and you do this it's
the best of both worlds
um
I think it takes a little bit away the
the magic in my opinion
um and for practical purposes if you
just want a good model you should
absolutely do this because it's going to
give you a smaller model that's more
performant but I think from a scientific
perspective you know the reason I'm I'm
so excited about gpd3 is that initially
is that you didn't have to do this and
um which means that
if you didn't try to do something but
you incidentally
you know did well on it that means
um it probably can do a lot of other
things beyond our kind of imagination so
this is a sort of a principle of
generalization and machine learning that
well if you don't look at it of course
you can fit the test set and then do
really well on the test set but if you
don't do that and you happen to do well
and test that then you know that you can
probably do well on new examples and
this is sort of taking it to the meta
level if you didn't
you know two not any
I guess in metal learning you could
classically you can say okay well I'm
not going to train on a task and
um
now I'm going to
you know and I've happened to do well on
some tasks I'll probably do one other
tasks but this is sort of going on
another level which is like okay there's
no notion of task and you see some of
the things that gpd3 can do like write
um a poem in the style of Shakespeare
about in context learning or something
and or do derived explanations and so
these are things that
um
you know like explaining something isn't
a task in in an at least in a
traditional sense it's sort of a
capability that's coupled with other
things and these things actually do
compose in a way so I think getting out
of the sort of x to Y mindset could help
you uh maybe unravel some of these other
deeper structures
of course this talk is complete about XY
pairs so just to be clear but I think
there's much more to do Beyond this
Sport and of course and things like that
was able to like latch onto that really
well but how else has worked it is
exactly
so it's pretty impressive that it had
ignored as priors But Then followed the
most prompt but then I imagine that
there's if there's any label noise I'm
not confused here so if you have like um
cucumber and pasta vegetable and then
beat to sport
yeah so the question is what happens if
you have noise in your labels
um I don't know what would happen
I think it I mean if I mean what's a
kind of the optimal thing to do it's
probably to balance the two somehow like
if you have just like
a little bit of noise then
um maybe it would just kind of ignore it
um the random label result shows that
it's sort of robust to noise and labels
um
and so maybe there if there's a kind of
determines the structure where it's not
random noise but if you're like flipping
then it latches onto that structure but
if there's no patterns there then you
just ignore it that would be what I
would hope that happens and I wouldn't
be surprised if it happens but you know
I I think you would need to run a more
careful experiment to know for sure
yeah but what about the complex learning
with like visual concepts because a lot
of the talk was about language and a lot
of metal learning Traditions I'm just
curious
about the vision because it's also like
different modalities those main concerts
starting to happen in different
modalities or is there something about
something special about confidence
yeah that's a really good question so
the question is uh what about vision and
as in context learning happened and
envision
um so that area is much less developed
than in language because we don't have
like a public tpg3 that everyone can
play with you know Flamingo from
deepmind I guess is a big model that can
do some in context learning for visual
inputs
um
but uh it's you know no one has access
to it
um publicly
um I do think that
something about language definitely
makes in context learning more natural
and easier
um in the sense that
you think about languages you know
inputs typically like here's a movie
where you classify it but language is
also
sort of operating at a mental level
right that's a power of language is that
it can you can describe tasks
and uh and a lot of
you know the internet probably has
things that do look like tasks I mean it
has to otherwise it's not it's only
limits to Magic I guess
um
so there's
so there's probably a lot of um you know
structured things that about language
that make in context learning work now
Envision
um
you know I would there's no I don't
think fundamental reason why you might
not
you I guess the thing is that you know
what are you doing in Vision like if
you're doing like classification you're
fundamentally going from like a kind of
a continuous visual space to some sort
of label space which is sort of language
in a sense and
and whereas in language inputs you're
already kind of in the language space
and that fluidity might help but I don't
know if there's any fundamental reason
you can't do in context learning and
um Envision or what what it would look
like
um
I mean I guess you could certainly train
models to do in context learning Vision
that I have you know a various High
faith in the Transformer to learn
complicated things whether it emerges
naturally from crawling the web with a
bunch of images I don't know really
depends on your data distribution
um Chelsea
the income tax order ing how desirable
properties of these over fine tuning but
it's also a lot
less uh do you think that that
reliability like there are ways to
increase that reliability or is that
just something more fundamental as a
result of being self-supervised uh and
like are there ways to make it more
reliable without
getting rid of the nice Parts about it
that's like
the question is can you make in context
learning more reliable
um so one answer is that if you do
instruction tuning you'll definitely
make it more reliable and this is what
everyone who's actually trying to make
these work and practice do
um
but you still might be concerned because
ultimately you're
um
if you're hoping that this Transformer
does something you know for you
um and that part
I think
you know at least these toy experiments
on linear regression shows that it's you
know it's under these pretty clean
conditions that can learn fairly
complicated you know functions
um
I think that
you know now if you have like
you know 100
000 examples you probably don't want to
just like prompt uh a language model
with those examples so it's in but then
yeah and if you have a lot of examples
you should probably be fine-tuning or
doing some sort of retrieval on those
anyway
um so I think this is
I guess maybe what I'll say is that
fuchsia learning is shouldn't be
reliable in the sense that it's
massively under specified so
I mean you shouldn't expect to do that
well unless you have strong priors
even if you're you know a fine tuning I
would say and in context learning is
sort of in that regime and
um
you know empirically I guess
um especially if you're doing
structuring it's not worse
um and if you're going to a lot more
examples then you're sort of in a
different regime and you should be yeah
doing great in updates
I've lost track
um here let's sweep the room I'll go
um with you and then switch this way
yeah
[Music]
do you think it might be coming from
this
write the label and then it's important
and then the model was trying to figure
out like what is of the task by the
language that my controlled on the maple
or because otherwise it doesn't I'm just
trying to figure out why it has such a
big game and like
was just randomizing yeah so the
question is uh why is the random labels
kind of working at all
um I mean I think that it's really
simple it's by looking at the inputs you
can kind of guess what the task should
be I guess is the answer like if you
look at these sentences it's like what
what do you what might someone want to
do with these example inputs and well
maybe classify sentiment
um
and I mean it's not obvious like it's
completely obvious but there has to be
kind of the thing that
um
what's doing
[Music]
minimize the words I think it should
work because
um yeah I think
but but I'm
well actually okay so you have to be a
little bit careful because
um
because if you put like a fruit
vegetable
then the model will probably want to
generate fruit and vegetable
right and then you're left wondering
like okay what do these labels mean
so yeah
um so enough functional space example we
actually had a fair idea that we need 20
examples
so in general like how do we think about
the harmony number of examples do you
need in your prompt for the classroom to
figure out what the task is and does
this how is that lead to the scale of
the Transformer
like how many examples should we get in
a problem to actually figure out the
task and does the scale matter in this
yeah so the question is here you have 20
examples and we know that you need 20
examples to learn this function what
about in general
certainly for real tasks I think this is
not really a I mean it's a hard and
ill-defined question because like how
many examples do you need to know
need for translation I think it depends
on the strength of your task prior
like if you already like one view is
that okay GB3 already knows how to do
tasks well all you're doing and context
learning is prompting like if you're
asking when someone born right zero shot
you don't know whether how you want to
format the date but if you see a few
examples you know what the date format
should be and that's all that's
happening so in that view the number of
examples is basically the number of
examples to figure out the format of the
task but not this true semantics
um
and I think that's
not an inaccurate view of what in
context Lorraine does because there's so
few examples I mean some of these tests
are like crazy and you can't really
figure it out unless you
um so so you can think about the
examples are there partly to help you
figure out what the task is and for that
inputs alone probably do and outputs I
guess in the test description all
contribute
um and then the the kind of the real
value of the examples is to really
figure out
like what the the format is
and so maybe you could try to formulate
uh you know a framework around thinking
about it in terms of
what is a space of tasks that
um and how many do you need to nail it
down
um which is you know maybe in very
little because there's just like a lot
of common things that you know people
talk about and once you see a
like in input you kind of know like okay
it's if I see text it's if I see code
it's probably going to be a code
question if I see like numbers it's
probably going to be a math question
that's not
um you know that gives me a lot of
information about the task and then you
need to figure out the format
um so yeah hopefully that helps
we get to maybe take one more or or end
there
you're the boss
okay
I was gonna return earlier
[Music]
on like what counts as like cheating so
like if I took clip and I transformed my
image into a caption right using
representations this way and like if you
were to go back to your example around
with you or do these analogies between
words right with like the sports
vegetables thing like
does that still count as in context
learning now for a different modality
um and I'm wondering like where do you
think compositionality plays
finding what a context learning is
so the question is like um
if you took clip and you turned all the
images into text and then you prompted
gpt3 would that be considered cheating
to declare that you have a
in context learning system for
Vision
phrase
It's just that like you're you're going
to cheat the process of learning the
representation I mean I think it's a
very practical thing to do and I think
there's a lot of work showing that you
should be leveraging these building
blocks as components right I don't think
you need to train like the mega
multimodal that does you know everything
I think we have language models and you
know people have gotten a lot of mileage
by prompt decomposition or chaining
things uh like Socratic models from you
know Google has this thing where the
models talk to each other
um and so I think from a systems
perspective yeah that's you know that's
great
um I think it's certainly not answering
the question of
like the emergent Behavior
because it's not introducing anything
new there's nothing new to say about
emergent Behavior if you change things
together
um
whereas compared to you know this
hypothetical experiment where you train
on you know web pages with the text and
the images and now can you
doing context learning with text and
images and in maybe both directions
generating text engineering images
that's a much more scientifically
interesting you know question
um
and you could probably if you did that
you again probably lead it would lead
you to some new emergent behaviors that
you wouldn't get if you just had you
know gpt3 and clip
okay
[Applause]